we're getting a glimpse today of what
2023 will bring to Las Vegas the Vegas
chamber offering a preview which also
included new leadership governor-elect
Joe Lombardo also made comments about
the vision for Nevada moving forward
governor-elect Joe Lombardo taking the
stage at the Vegas chamber luncheon at
the win on Friday to address the
business Community I'm looking forward
to working with the chamber in
Partnership and moving this state
forward the Vegas Chambers president and
CEO Mary Beth seawalt says the last few
years were tough as many small
businesses were affected by the pandemic
she hopes the upcoming lineup of major
events like Formula One can help
it's incredibly important to have
someone like Formula One On The Board of
the Vegas chamber
obviously the impacts the economic
impacts of formula one coming to our
destination are going to be absolutely
Monumental SeaWorld says the domino
effect from major events like Formula
One and other sports events will help
small businesses connect she says there
is also a lot of planning ahead of the
upcoming legislative session with a
chamber plans to collaborate with
governor-elect Lombardo and his new
Administration we have a legislative
session starting up in in February and
so we're excited to get up and talk to
legislators about our priorities
certainly wanting to make sure that we
keep the business climate productive and
competitive and free from any additional
taxes and regulations a process that is
going to be
symbiotic a process that is going to
move the state forward for a great place
to live
well we should mention governor-elect
Joe Lombardo will take office in January